a disruptive new year's eve after drag
racing in one northwest valley
neighborhood listen to that it's another
complaint after months of similar
activity all over the northwest valley
and in north las vegas this most recent
situation happened last night near grand
canyon and gown road madison kimbrough
is live tonight with what one woman
describes as a terrifying ordeal madison
yeah street racing in the northwest
valley is nothing new but according to
neighbors last night on
new year's eve a whole new ordeal take a
listen
hundreds of people swarmed the area of
grand canyon and gowen as cars zipped up
and down racing at all hours of the
night new year's eve remnants of
headlights and other car parts could be
found on the street after the racing
took place carrie who lives right around
the corner says this type of racing
occurs almost every weekend but last
night was especially alarming since
there were so many people out standing
around in crowds neighbors say they
called police but officers never showed
when kerry made the report she was told
to get their license plates but says it
was hard to do so in fear of getting hit
or threatened these uh individuals were
doing these 360s and fast it was so fast
they could have lost control at any time
in fact at some points i thought these
kids were going to get killed they're
just ripping up the road
they don't care about their own safety
so why should they care about anybody
else's safety neighbors say this
incident looked organized with people
using professional cameras filming which
is a commonality with these racing
groups who often post their racing
videos to youtube
we plan on continuing this story later
tonight so we will see if any street
racing takes place while we are out here
reporting live in the northwest valley
madison kimbrough live local now